good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
studying today is SCP 49 object class
Euclid special containment procedures
SCP 49 is contained within a standard
secure humanoid containment cell in
research sector 2 at site 19 SCP 49 must
be sedated before any attempts to
transport it during transport SCP 49
must be secured within a class 3
humanoid restriction harness including a
locking collar and extension restraints
and monitored by no fewer than two armed
guards while SCP 49 is generally
cooperative with most foundation
personnel outbursts or sudden changes in
behavior are to be met with elevated
force under no circumstances should any
personnel come into direct contact with
a CP 49 during these outbursts in the
event SCP 49 becomes aggressive the
application of lavendar L multivator has
been shown to produce a calming effect
on the entity once calmed SCP 49
generally becomes compliant and will
return to containment with little
resistance in order to facilitate the
ongoing containment of SCP 49 the entity
is to be provided with a corpse of a
recently deceased animal typically a
bovine or other large mammal once every
two weeks for study corpses that become
instances of scp-1404 Massie P 49 s
containment cell and incinerated SCP 49
is no longer permitted to interact with
human subjects and requests for human
subjects are to be denied temporary
containment procedure update see
addendum 49.3% Eamon committee order
zero four nine point s nineteen point
17.1 SCP 49 is no longer permitted to
interact directly with any members of
foundation staff No
to be provided with any additional
corpses to be used in its surgeries this
order shall persist indefinitely until
such time a consensus regarding the
ongoing containment of a CP 49 can be
reached description as CP 49 is a
humanoid entity roughly 1.9 meters in
height which bears the appearance of a
medieval plague dr. Weil SCP 49 appears
to be wearing thick robes and the
ceramic mask indicative of that
profession the garments instead seem to
have grown out of a CP 49 s body over
time and are now nearly
indistinguishable from whatever form is
beneath them x-rays indicate that
despite this SCP 49 does have a humanoid
skeletal structure beneath its outer
layer SCP 49 is capable of speech in a
variety of languages though it tends to
prefer English or medieval French while
SCP 49 is generally cordial and
cooperative with foundation staff it can
become easily irritated or at times
outright aggressive if it feels that it
is in the presence of what it calls the
pestilence although the exact nature of
this pestilence is currently unknown to
foundation researchers it does seem to
be an issue of immense concern to SCP 49
CP 49 will become hostile with
individuals it sees as being affected by
the pestilence often having to be
restrained should it encounter such if
left unchecked SCP 49 will generally
attempt to kill any such individual SCP
49 is capable of causing all biological
functions of an organism to cease
through direct skin contact how this
occurs is currently unknown and
autopsies of SCP 49s victims have been
variably been inconclusive
as CP 49 has expressed frustration or
remorse after these killings indicating
that they have done little to kill the
pestilence though will usually seek to
perform a crude surgery on the corpse
using the influence contained within a
black doctor's bag it carries on its
person at all times while these
surgeries are not always successful
they often result in the creation of
instances of scp-1404 t92 instances are
reanimated corpses that have been
operated on by a CP 49 these instances
do not seem to retain any of their prior
memories or mental functions having only
basic motor skills and response
mechanisms while these instances are
generally inactive moving very little
and in a generally ambulatory fashion
they can become extremely aggressive if
provoked or if directed to Baia CP 49
SCP 49 two instances Express active
biological functions though these are
vastly different from currently
understood human physiology despite
these alterations SCP 49 often remarks
that the subjects have been cured
addendum 49.1 discovery SCP 49 was
discovered during the investigation of a
series of unknown disappearances in the
town of Montalban in southern France
during a raid on a local home
investigators found several instances of
scp-1404 de 9 while law enforcement
personnel engaged the hostile 49 to
instances SCP 49 was noted as watching
the engagement and taking notes in its
journal after all of the 49 two
instances were dispatched SCP 49
willingly entered foundation custody
the following interview was conducted by
dr. Raymond ham during the initial
investigation
interviewer dr. Raymond ham cite 85
interviewee SCP 49 playing log now said
French can we get a translator King's
English don't need for translation sir I
can speak it well enough good
my name is dr. Raymond ham and I ha a
doctor
I like minded individual on their down
where in is your speciality sir crypto
biology why a medical man such as myself
wonders abound and here I worried I have
been abducted by common street thugs
this place then this is your laboratory
I had wondered as clean as it is and
with such little trace of the best ones
here the best of us
what do you mean the scourge the great
dying come now you know there what is it
they call it the best ones yes it
abounds outside these walls you know so
many have succumbed and many more will
continue to until such time as a perfect
cure in B develop fortunately I am very
close it is my duty in life to rid the
world of it you see the cure to end all
cures
when you will say the great dying are
you talking about the bubonic plague I
don't know what that is
see right well entities are ages
character house they were dead when you
encountered them yes you reanimated them
in a manner of speaking you see things
to simply doctor expand your horizons
life and death sickness and health
these are perverted terms for amateur
physicians there is only one that
ailment that exists in the world of men
and that is the pestilence and nothing
else make no mistake they were very you
know all of them you take you're cured
those people indeed my cure is most
effective are the thing is we recovered
were not human yes well it is not
perfect to cure but that will come with
time and further experimentation I have
spent a lifetime and will spend a
lifetime more if necessary now we have
wasted too much time there is work to do
I will require a laboratory of my own
one where I can continue my research
unimpeded and assistance of course
though I can provide those on my own
time I don't think I would be willing
Thomasson's we are all men of science
that's your code and show me to my
quarters doctor begins now
interviewers note while SCP 49 is
capable of communicating in a very human
way there is a strange sense of unease
the one experiences when in its presence
make no mistake there is something very
uncanny about this entity indeed
additionally we've confiscated that
point it's stick that SCP 49 keeps
waving around part of this was due to
standard confiscation protocols or the
possession of anomalies and part because
49 really is a menace swinging it around
like you
the entity was displeased at first but
after we made some concessions in
providing it with test subjects which
are admittedly more for the benefit of
our own research it warmed up to the
idea
addendum forty-nine point two
observation look while in containment at
site 19 SCP 49 has spent a considerable
amount of time studying and performing
surgery on the various mammalian corpses
it had been provided as CP 49 will
routinely spends several days performing
surgery and then regardless of whether
or not the corpse becomes an instance of
scp-1407 ace documenting its findings in
a thick leather journal stored within
its doctors bag as CP 49 will often seek
to share its findings with members of
foundation staff the following is a log
of several occasions during which SCP 49
was observed operating on a mammalian
corpse observational log 49 point oh L
point one summary subject SCP 49 preface
a test subject d85 123 was introduced
into SCP 49 s containment cell the
entity expressed sincere gratitude
towards all members of the containment
and research now observation notes SCP
49 began by asking 285 123 several
standard medical questions as it began
removing tools from its bag shortly
after finishing its preparations SCP 49
quickly closed the distance between the
two killing the subject with a touch to
its throat afterwards SCP 49 made a
number of considerable alterations to
the basic structure of the subjects
corpse often introducing fluids from
within its bag into the subject by way
of a hand-powered pump and copper tubing
the resulting 49 - instance became
animated flailing and grasping at the
walls of the chamber with a number of
manufactured limbs while moaning out of
an oblong orifice now present in its
sternum
during this time SCP 49 was observed
taking notes of the instance in its
journal and remarking to the watching
research staff about the efficacy of its
cure security personnel entered the
chamber to move SCP 49 back to
containment and were attacked by the
instance the security team dispatched
the 49 to instance and a CP 49 returned
to containment with no resistance
stating that it was pleased with the
results
observational log 49 point ll point to
summary subject SCP 49 preface SCP 49
was provided the corpse of a recently
deceased goat SCP 49 expressed gratitude
at the provision observation notes SCP
49 operated on the goat corpse for
several days eventually resulting in an
instance of scp-1498 49 expressed
pleasure in this outcome though admitted
the disease was still in its nascent
stage my veterinarian practice is
rudimentary but the patient responded
well to the procedure observational log
49 point o L point 3 summary subject SCP
49 preface SCP 49 was provided the
corpse of a recently deceased or rang
attack SCP 49 expressed noted gratitude
at the provision due to the similarities
between the orangutan and common human
physiology observation notes SCP 49
spent several days operating on the
orangutan reanimating at several times
however SCP 49 appeared to be discontent
with the results it experienced
returning to the creature three times
after its initial reanimation for
additional work after it was unable to
reanimate the corpse a fifth time SCP 49
turned the corpse over to foundation
staff for incineration stating I have
learned so much from this though I fear
my early optimism was misplaced I hadn't
yet come across such a stumbling block
on my
to the cure more subjects like this
would do a great deal in advancing my
research observational log forty-nine
point oh l 0.7 full subject SCP 49
preface SCP 49 was provided the corpse
of a recently deceased bovine SCP 49
expressed mild annoyance at the
provision though it accepted it
nonetheless observation notes SCP 49
spent several days operating on the
bovine corpse breaking only to dine on a
request at dinner of thin crackers
salted pork and hard cheese beginning
first by embalming the corpse SCB 49 and
was observed producing a number of long
syringes from its bag each containing a
different dark viscous fluid SCP 49
described these fluids as essences of
the humors and elaborated by saying the
pestilence may bring about a systemic
imbalance in such case before true
healing can begin one must find the
humors in balance or the body will
reject the cure over the next few days
SCP 49 spent a considerable amount of
time adjusting the organs of the bovine
corpse with a number of large metal
instruments after eight days SCP 49
produced a lightning rod which dr. Ham
exchanged for an electric cattle prod
attached to an extension cord and struck
the corpse in several locations
this action seemingly had the effect of
reanimating the bovine which once again
became ambulatory despite the inversion
of the head and reorientation of its
limbs and this is a follow-up interview
to the previous observation logs playing
log now
we watched you work for several weeks
now and honestly up I'm not sure I
understand what you're doing could you
describe your process in detail
oh goodness now processes most intensive
as I said to your assistant the best
instruction you will find about my
methods are here in my journals as I
have kept exhaustive records of my work
there see well my concern doctor is that
we still don't understand what you're
seeking to cure how it manifests or how
turning these creatures quasi living
mindless drones helps in that effort you
do not understand the pestilence even
after all this time doctor it is an
unspeakable aura one that has shown its
true face many times before and well
again I find myself blessed with the
wisdom and good senses needed to root it
out and destroy it but many like
yourself cannot it is a cruel judgment I
fear to be at the mercy of a disease you
cannot fully comprehend that still
doesn't answer my question
how's your cure and they kind of cure at
all it is a cure you may laugh at my
efforts if you please but do not merge
the good name of scientific progress
that has developed this great mercy what
you should sighted Lee see here is a
life better than any this creature could
have hoped for
stricken as it was with the pestilence
this creature is now clean unable to
spread the pestilence and free from the
terror it would have experienced
otherwise
this is hardly a creature at all dr.
sadi do not [ __ ] with me sir you and your
colleagues are like so many others are
they able to look past - setbacks to see
the salvation taking place before your
very eyes do you wait to remove rotten
Timbers until the hole collapses on top
of you now you find them and you pull
them out and replace them with those
untouched by rot and most of all you do
not simply mock the structure because it
now looks different to you it is strong
it is free of disease I'm sorry it mean
to agitate you I'm I'm just trying to
understand yes well do mind your words
in the future doctor I am a professional
but even professionals may feel the bite
of pride in dealing with criticism of
their masterpiece I will forgive this as
an act of good faith between colleagues
there anything else I can help you with
no another test subject on the usual
schedule you know my preference of
subjects with more human anatomies
attending researchers note SCP 49 does
seem to genuinely want to help other
humans though it does not yet been able
to provide a concrete example of what
exactly it is trying to save us all from
I have watched it now for several weeks
and while the outcomes do not seem to
ever change SCP 49 continues to claim
that it is growing closer to its perfect
cure
I think the entity may be more aware of
the reality of these outcomes than it
would like us to think
addendum 49.3 April 16 2017 incident
starting shortly after a cp-40 nines
initial containment dr. hem conducted a
number of interviews with the subject
regarding its anomalous properties and
over time began to note its displeasure
with its subject n SCP 49 two instances
this continued for a period of several
months during which SCP 49 never
exhibited any aggressive behaviors on
April 16th 2017 as dr. ham was entering
a CP 49
test chamber to conduct another routine
interview the entity began to grow
anxious and asked dr. ham if he was
feeling well following protocol
dr. ham reminded SCP 49 that the
interview was required after which the
entity became hostile and attacked dr.
ham killing him due to a lapse in
security protocol and because dr. ham
did not activate the in chamber
emergency system dr. hams corpse was not
discovered until three hours later by
which point SCP 49 had converted it into
an instance of scp-1404 math of this
incident SCP 49 was interviewed by dr.
Theron Sherman playing log now I need
you to explain yourself scp-049 you are
being directed to explain your actions
and I will remind you that failure to
cooperate will result in further
restrictions during your containment my
actions explain you killed Raymond ham
and then butchered him until you're dead
no cured cured of what pestilence what
pestilence you keep going on and on
about this pestilence but you have not
once been able to properly identify this
disease
what could you have possibly seen in him
today that you had not seen so many
times before that it would be worth his
life the best lence presents and
progresses in unforeseeable fashions and
has a clear way of of creeping into the
unprepared and call it what you want
doctor it was a mercy I did damn he is
cured he is a vegetable I I would not
expect you to understand even your your
ilk have proven time and time again not
to be men of science but menno's of
emotion you cannot appreciate dollar as
I've seen there's many millions who have
succumbed to the pestilence had been
changed your cure cost ray his life now
good sir I have saved it you will allow
this world to slip back into the despair
of disease and death ignoring that I
have created a miracle and what disease
what pestilence he was a healthy man he
was a good doctor I'm offering it freely
to the afflicted
you are not worth this argument sir
he was short sighted and foolish dr.
hammer was sick and I i cured him I am
the only one who can do this my work
must continue there is still so much to
learn so much I've had enough of this
consider your allowances will saved even
you welcome to containment go for sign
might be saved
we're done here I can save them all I
can cast down this plague once and for
all I can do this only me I I saved
I saved him dr. Hammond I I cured him he
was sick I know really was sick I know
he was and I you are all sick but I I
can save you I can say all of you
because I addendum forty nine point four
post incident report interview the
following interview is an excerpt from
the April 16 2017 forty nine incident
report the interview was conducted by
dr. elijah it can to place three weeks
after the start of the initial
investigation playing now scp-049 we are
conducting this interview to close out
our investigation of your actions taken
on April 16th that are resulted in the
death of a staff member you have any
comments to make only that I look
forward to the day when you will allow
me to resume my work I have spent the
last few weeks compiling my notes and
instructing a new theory for how the
pestilence was able to infect someone in
such an insidious manner that I nearly
couldn't detect it have you experienced
any remorse for your actions for the
death of dr. ham oh yes well the death
of a colleague is always regrettable but
in the face of the best ones we must be
swift doctor an act without hesitation
dr. Schurman noted in his report that
you seemed to be mournful during your
initial interview perhaps it is
lamentable that a fellow doctor became
infected but the work continues
regrettable Asst as it was dr. hams
death provided important insight living
human subjects are the only way to
proceed forward
I am decided my cure is of little use on
dead flesh and I have claimed all I can
from your generous supply of corpses my
desires turn towards tending to those
still living who suffer from the disease
I'm afraid you're going to be
disappointed I wouldn't be so sure okay
I think that about does it for today
thank you all for listening if indeed
you still are and you're all dismissed
goodbye
hi everyone so before the patreon
thank-yous I would like to thank people
that contributed to this video all of
the links to their YouTube channels or
their respective websites will be in the
description so I encourage you to go and
check the might because they're all
great number one was Sherm from site 42
number two was dr. Sumerian voice actor
and author links will be in the
description
DJ cactus was the guy that was
responsible for the rewrite and finally
Gabriel giad who was the original author
of scp-049 if you visit the SCP wiki
page for scp-049 you will find the logs
that you've heard in this video and this
was a pretty big deal for me because
this pretty much means that my tick on
the e04 9 voice is common I'm not but
that is awesome month it's a really good
feeling I've been voicing this character
for I don't know like five years now I
to be officially part of the document as
the voice of the SCP it's just great
again all links in the descriptions for
everything on everyone who helped with
this video and that's everything so I'm
gonna thank my patrons night goodbye I
would like to give a special thank you
to Andre Bashar Muslim Mookie Jax
Merrick Pierce M Hamlin Austin Thomas
Aldridge Desmond Hoskins Depp's McGee
dr. mortis John O Porter
Cody tench ty burr ball on sy7 actual if
you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
volume thank you
[Music]
you